في ثالث يوم على زلزال المغرب فرق الانقاص
تسابق الزمن للوصول الى لاجين وسط صعوبات
في المناطق الجبليه والنائيه القوات
المسلحه المغربيه تدفع بتعزيزات لدعم
عمليات الانقاذ في اكثر المناطق تضرا
بمركز الزلزال وفرق انقاذ عربيه ودوليه
تتوجه للمساهمه في الاغاثه
الضحايا يتجاوزون 2100 قتيل معظمهم في
اقليم الحوز جنوب مراكش تشكيل خليه ازمه
حكوميه لتنسيق التدخلات والجزيره ترصد
عمليات البحث ورفع الانقاذ في منطقه مركز
الزلزال
الاف يبتون في العراء وسط مخاوف من هزات
ارتداديه الصليب الاحمر ينبه الى ان
احتواء اثار الكارثه اجتماعيا واقتصاديا
قد يتطلب سنوات ويونسكو ترسل بعثه للمغرب
للوقوف على المعالم الاثريه المتضرره جراء
الزلزال
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد في هذه التغطيه
المستمره لزلزال المغرب
[موسيقى]
جهود حثيثه تستمر سعيا للوصول الى ناجينا
في اليوم الثالث على الزلزال اخر الارقام
بحسب داخليه المغربيه تقول ان عدد الضحايا
ارتفع الى
الفينلا بينما بلغ عدد المصابين الفين
2421 واعلنت الحكومه المغربيه انشاء خليه
ازمه تحت اشراف وزاره الداخليه لمتابعه
ودعم جهود الاغاثه وضمان حسن سير عمليه
الانقاذ
المشهد على الارض مع عثمان اي فرح وشبكه
مراسلين اليك عثمان
[موسيقى]
شكرا جلال ما زال كثيرون هنا يحاولون
التعامل مع الصدمه النفسيه التي واجهوها
هي بضع ثوان اهتزت فيها الارض وسقطت
البيوت على رؤوس ساكنيها والكثيرون فقدوا
احبتهم كما ذكرت اخر حصيله تتحدث عن اكثر
من الفي قتيل واكثر من 2000 جريح وما زالت
الجهود متواصله للبحث عن ناجين طبعا مع
مرور الوقت تصبح فرصه الحصول على ناجين
اصعب ولكن الجهود مستمره ايضا هناك صعوبه
في الوصول الى بعض الاماكن نظرا لصعوبه
تضاريس ووعوره الطرق خاصه في المناطق
الجبليه
للمزيد من التفاصيل ونقرب الصوره اكثر مع
شبكه مراسلينا مختار العدلاوي من اقليم
الحوز ايمن الزبير من تارودانت ومن
مراكش سعيد بوخفه وابدا معك سعيد ثالث
ليلى بيت فيها الالاف في ما هي
مشاهداتك في مراكش
بالفعل عثمان حياه المراكشيين اختلفت من
بعد ليله الجمعه الماضيه التي فاجئهم فيها
الزلزال فهم كانوا متعودين على قضاء
اللياليهم في بيوتهم اليوم هنا الصوره
ربما خلفي هي اوضح بكثير واوضح دليل على
كيف يقضي
المراكشيون لياليهم هنا الاسر هنا اطفال
وكبار وشيوخ موجودون في
الاماكن العامه والحدائق
العامه حيث هناك خشيه كبيره من الهزات
الارتداديه التي نسمع كلام كثير هنا في
مراكش عن ان الهزات ربما قد تحدث
في اي وقت هناك من يتحدث عن مواعيد وهناك
ما يتحدث عن معلومات علميه ان الهزات
الارتداديه قد تكون اقوى لان الدرجه التي
ضرب بها الزلزال كانت قويه وبالتالي
الردات او الارتدادات قد تكون اقوى اذا
المراكشيون يخشون هذه
الارتدادات فيقضون لياليهم هنا في هذه
الحدائق
والمتنزهات خارج البيوت
ليست خيم وانما بعض الاقمشه التي ربما
جمعوها بسرعه قبل ان يغادروا بيوتهم
الجميع هنا يخشى من البيوت الايه للسقوط
حتى البيوت التي ربما لم تصب خلال الزلزال
لكنهم يخشون ان تكون عائله للسقوط لان
الكثير من البيوت هي بيوت تراثيه هنا في
مراكش في الساحه التي اتواجد فيها هنا او
ساحه الواحه او شارع الواحه هناك اعداد
كبيره من
يوجدون في هذا المكان ربما الاخبار الساره
التي قد تثلج صدورهم في خلال الساعات
القادمه عثمان هي وصول المساعدات صحيح هم
مقتنعون ان السلطات المغربيه تقوم بواجبها
بشكل جيد وهناك تنسيق جيد سواء من السلطات
المحليه اليوم عمده مدينه مراكش كانت هنا
في وسط المدينه وقد زارت العديد من الناس
والاهالي هنا لكن ايضا الناس
مقتنعون ان السلطات تقوم بواجبها على اكمل
وجه لكن المساعدات بدات تصل اليوم قبل
قليل فقط قبل ساعتين من الان وصلت طائرتان
قطريتان محملتان
بالمساعدات وكذلك
الفريق انقاذ سيساعد في
العمليات الاغاثه ربما العمليات الاكثر هي
في المناطق المجاوره
لمدينه مراكش
والمناطق المحيطه بها التي تاثرت كثيرا
لان مباراه الزلزال كانت
احوال حول المدينه مراكش كما تعرف البؤره
الزلزال هي
كما عندما تلقي بحجره في وسط بركه مائيه
فتكون الذبذبات اقوى في المناطق المحيطه
كما سمعنا من الخبراء هنا الذين تحدثنا
اليهم هذا الصباح تماما الاخبار تماما
سعيد
وكما ذكرت نعم وكما ذكرت سعيد عموما صحيح
بدات بدات بالوصول بالفعل وكان ايضا هناك
كلمه للناطق باسم الحكومه وقال ان رئيس
الوزراء رئيس الحكومه سوف يتراس اللجنه
المكلفه باعاده ترميم المباني المتضرره
والحكومه هنا ايضا مستنفره بشكل كامل
لمساعده المتضررين وكما ذكرت هناك مساعدات
ايضا بدات بالوصول من عده
جهات
وتحدثت عن بؤره الزلزال او مركزه وذلك كان
في الحوز المختار العملاوي معنا من هناك
صعوبه الوصول الى بعض الاماكن يعني صعب من
ايصال المساعدات الى الناس هل الان في
الحوز تحديدا هناك قدره على فك العزله عن
ما يعرف هناك بالدوائر الجبليه المختار
نعم عثمان لربما هذا المشهد الذي نشاهد
الان هو يعكس جانب من الجواب لماذا لانه
في امزميز في هذا الوقت من سنه وايضا في
هذا التوقيت من اليوم لا تكون الحركه بهذه
الكثافه بالنظر الى ان امزميز بلده صغيره
لكن وبفعل الطرق التي فتحت خلال الساعات
الماضيه والتي نجحت فيها السلطات في فتحها
مع العلم ان ليس جميع الطرق فتحت لكن
الطرق التي فتحت خلال الساعات الماضيه
مكنت هؤلاء الناس من القدوم الى امزميز
والى ضواحي امزميز بهدف تقديم المساعدات
وهذه هي الحركه هؤلاء هذه السيارات
بالتحديد هي قادمه من المناطق الجبليه
واخرى متجهه الى المناطق الجبليه
لتقديم المزيد من الدعم هذه السيارات اتت
من مراكش ومن الرباط ومن الدار البيضاء
وحتى من طنجه تحمل المساعدات الاساسيه
كالاغذيه والادويه والاغطيه لتقديمها الى
سكان المناطق
المتضرره في الحوز عن واقع هذه المنطقه
نستضيف السيد حسن وهو من سكان المنطقه
استاذ حسن قبل قليل كنت تزور المناطق
الجبليه كيف هو الواقع
الطرقات هي مفتوحه ام لا
رصد الجبال هل هي الصخور الانجرافات
الجرافات
اهم احتياجات التي يحتاجها الناس في تلك
المناطق لنا المشهد ماذا رايت مساعده
ذلك الان
[موسيقى]
رشيد حكى لنا جانب من هذا الواقع حيث قال
هو وايضا شهود عيان ان بعض الطرقات
تعرضت لنهيارات كبيره وهناك اجزاء صخريه
اعاقت حركه السير ولهذا خلال الساعات
الماضيه راينا تعزيزات قامت بها القوات
المسلحه الملكيه في هذه الاتجاهات
بالتحديد من اجل المساهمه في فك العزله عن
هذه المناطق
المتضرره هنا ايضا في امس ميز لا يزال
السكان يعانون بفعل الانهيارات المنزليه
الاسم الكريم رشيد رشيد شاب اضطره الى
مغادره بيته مع اسرته والان يبيت في
العراء كيف تص
مره اخرى اذا هناك مخاوف من عوده الهزات
الارتداديه نعم هناك مخاوف
بطبيعه الحال
تقريبا ممكن اسبوع في الشارع لاخذ
الاحتياطات اللازمه من كيف عشت هذه
التجربه بالاساس احكي لنا جوانب انك تكون
في البيت الان بدون بيت
الامر صعب صراحه
خصوصا من ناحيه الماكل
والجو يعني في الليل نواجه بعض الصعوبات
في يعني
هناك بعض البروده الجو بارد في خصوصا في
اوقات الفجر
طبعا يجب
ان تاخذ الاحتياطات للنوم
ان تستعد من جميع الجوانب ما هذا خطوره
المنزل الذي تسكننا فيه الذي كنتم تسكنون
فيه ما مدى درجه الخطوره فيه نعم صراحه
خطوره ليست كبيره في منزل بالنسبه لحالتي
لكن في منازل اخرى يعني اتوقع اذا عاد
الزلزال مره اخرى
ايضا اسمحلي عثمان سمعنا خلال الساعات
القليله الماضيه من السكان المحليين ان
فرق الانقاذ نجحت في انقاذ اعداد مهمه من
الضحايا بعضهم على قيد الحياه بعضهم فارغ
ولهذا كنا خلال الساعات الماضيه ايضا
نشاهد سيارات الاسعاف باعداد كبيره تمر
بسرعه نحو المستشفيات
ونحن الان نشاهد صور لعمليات الانقاذ في
الحوز الحوز كان يعني مركز هذا الزلزال
اقليم الحوز الذي يتحدث منهم مختار
العبلاوي وهذه اخبار طيبه للغايه انه في
الساعات الماضيه تمكن فرق الانقاذ من
الوصول الى بعض
النازيين هذه الصور الان
نعرضها على الهواء كما قلت لا زال هناك
تشبث بالامل مهما مر الوقت يعني لا نعلم
اذا كان مازال هناك نازون فقط الجميع
يتثبت بالامل والى اخر لحظه يستمرون في
جهودهم هذه رغمه صعوبه الامر بسبب
التضاريس في اماكن مثل الحوز تارودانت
ايضا كانت من المناطق التي تضررت كثيرا
ايمن الزبير معنا من هناك لا شك ان جهود
الانقاذ مستمره في تارودانت ايضا هذه
المنطقه التي يعني للاسف عائلات باكملها
قضت فيها في هذا الزلزال
نعم عثمان نحن في قريه اشكال دائما في
خانز
وخط الانترنت مقطوع لذلك لم نتمكن من
الظهور مباشره عبر الكاميرا هنا ايضا
الصوره معقده في هذه القريه الصغيره كل
البيوت مدمره تقريبا سكان هذه القريه
فقدوا 43 من ذويهم لكن رغم هذه الاساس
الانسانيه هناك نوع من
الارتياح لان هذه القريه منذ اللحظه
الاولى كانت معزوله الطريق اليها كان
مقطوعا تم فتح هذا الطريق وما نشاهده الان
في هذا المكان تحديدا هو
المواطنين المغاربه بتقديم المساعده
للضحايا
مستمره من السيارات الخاصه تصل تباعا الى
هذا المكان لتقديم كل اشكال المساعده خاصه
المساعده الغذائيه وتوفير
في قريه يحيى المشكله
لدى هؤلاء هي عدم توفر خيم الكل هنا ينام
في الشارع خوفا من الارتدادات
الابتدائيه وبالتالي المشهد مهم جدا في
هذه البلده في هذه الساعات من الليل نشاهد
العشرات من المواطنين في
الشارع ولكن النقطه الايجابيه كما اشارت
هي وصول المساعده ايضا في القرى الاخرى
ونحن نغادر قريه
سيدنا مواطنين
كانوا
في ملصقات
الصوت يتقطع ايمن وكما اشرت يعني ربما
هناك مشكله في الانترنت وهذا مفهوم في ظل
هذه الظروف عموما ايمن ايمن الزبير طوال
الساعات الماضيه وهو ينقل لنا الصوره في
ولكن هذه الصور التي نشاهدها هي من الحوز
اقليم الحوز وهو مركز الزلزال هذا الزلزال
الذي تضرر بسببه نحو 300 الف في المغرب
حسب ما ذكرته منظمه الصحه العالميه
واذا يعني الشيء الايجابي كما كان يقول
ايمن ان بعض المناطق التي كان من الصعب ان
تصل اليه الى المساعدات بدات تصل بالفعل
ومنها ما يعرف بالدوائر الجبليه في الحوز
وكان من الصعب الوصول اليها وما زالت
الجهود مستمره وصلت بعض التعزيزات الى
الحوز اما هنا في مراكش
يعني المشكله الاساسيه هي ان الناس يبيتون
في العراء لانهم يخشون من العوده الى
منازلهم التي هي خاصه القديمه منها يرون
انها قائله للسقوط وبسبب نوبه الهلع التي
عاشوها ويخشون من اثار الهزات الارتداديه
التي لا يعلمون ان كانت ستاتي ومتى ستاتي
وباي قوه ستاتي واي اثر
ستترك على كل حال نشكر شبكه مراسلينا سعيد
بخفه من مراكش من اقليم الحوز المختل
عبلاوي ومن تارودانت ايمن الزبير ونواصل
هذه التغطيه معك جلال شكرا لك عثمان
ولشبكه مراسلينا في هذه الاثناء ذكرت
القوات المسلحه المغربيه في حسابها على
منصه اكس ان تعزيزات كبيره من الجيش
المغربي وصلت الى منطقه امزميز في ضواحي
مدينه مراكش وذلك لدعم جهود عمليه الانقاذ
وانتشار جثامين ضح ايا زلزال المدمر الذي
ضرب المنطقه كما اظهرت صور بثها الجيش
وصول مروحيات عسكريه الى اقليم الحوز مركز
الزلزال حامله مواد اغاثه لتوزيعها على
المنكوبين
ساعات من العمل المضني هل تنبثق الحياه من
تحت الركام ليس هذه المره فجهود فرق البحث
والانقاذ انتهت هنا الى انتشال مزيد من
الجثث
في دموع هذا الرجل الم لفقدان ابنائه
ورجاء بالعثور على زوجته حيه بين الانقاض
المراحيه
على امل العثور على ناجين تستمر عمليات
رفع الانقاض في المناطق المنكوبه الجبليه
النائيه في عمومها ومع تكشف اعداد ضحايا
الزلزال تكبر محنه المغرب
الله اكبر تؤدى صلاه الغائب في مختلف
انحاء المملكه لكن احدا لا ينسى من خلفهم
الزلزال وراءه
انهم اكثر من ثلاثمائه الف متضرر في مراكش
وضواحيها
في مشاف المنطقه حاله استنفار فصول ضحايا
الزلزال اليها لا يكاد يتوقف
قد يشكل تقديم رعايه الطبيه والاسعافات
الاوليه هنا تحديا تخفف من وقعه هذه الهبه
التضامنيه وتعين عليه
شاهد المغاربه وحتى الاجانب يتقاتلون الى
مراكز التبرع بالدم تلبيه لنداء السلطات
الصحيه من ولد قال لي
لهذا خاصنا خاصنا
بزاف الناس
هذا صراحه في المغاربه
العنايه بفئه اخرى من المتضررين شردها
الزلزال جعلتها سلطات البلد اولويه قد
يلزم لزوال الصدمه التي المت بمثل هؤلاء
سنوات بحسب الخبراء
صحيح ان الخيام ومراكز اللواء المؤقته
يصعب ان تعوض بيوتا فقدوها او خرجوا منها
مجبرين لكنهم يشعرون بالامتنان امام تضافر
جهود كهذا الذي تقوده الوقايه المدنيه في
منطقه امزميز ومع ذلك يتطلب الموقف المزيد
لا تناقش ما كاينش من النهار الاول
الناس
المساعده في الوقت
تضرر الطرق بفعل الانهيارات الصخريه التي
حركها الزلزال ما زال يعوق جهود الاغاثه
وتوزيع المساعدات لاسيما على طريق الرابطه
بين مراكش وتارودانت الى واحد من تجاليات
كارثه بدا ضررها الاكبر في مركز الهزه
باقليم الحوز الواقع في جهه مراكش اسفي
عرفتنا الكارثه على اسماء قرى كمولاي
ابراهيم وايت يحيى وايت اورير واسني
وايغيل قرى قلبت عظائم المحن عزلتها هناك
في اعالي الجبال الى حمله تضامن عابره
للحدود مع المغرب في مصابه
الينا من مدينه اكادير عبد اللطيف وهبي
وزير العدل المغربي سيد الوزير اذا
الحكومه اعلنت عن تشكيل خليه ازمه ما
اولويتها في هذه المرحله
مساء الخير هي الاولويه الاساسيه هو انهاء
معها او البحث عن الجثث والبحث عن
العالقين في الانصات هذه والهدف الاول
والاساسي الذي تم تقديم الماء والطعام
والخيال
للضحايا هذا الزلزال وكذلك الاهتمام
بالمعطوبين
المشتريات هذه الاولويات الان في هذه
اللحظه وجهود الاغاثه الى اين وصلت
في الحقيقه في منطقه سوس
مسحنا كل المنطقه في منطقتين سوداويتين
بؤرتين وهي موجوده
بمنطقه جبليه وهران جدا اسمها
التذكر اسمها
هذه النقطتين
في العمق لم نستطع نصل اليها لان الجبل
سقط على الطريق ونهار نحو
نحو الوادي فلا يستطيع السيارات تحول
الجيش ان يمر حول الدفاع المدني ان يمر
بدون وفي الاخير استعملنا الطائرات
هليكوبتر والحوامات لنقل الجرحى للماء
والطعام للناس القاتلون بهذه المناطق كما
تابعنا قبل قليل مع مراسلينا الطرق تفتح
والمساعدات تصل اضافه الى المنطقه التي
ذكرتها الان هل ما زالت هناك مناطق معزوله
سيد الوزير
لان الجيش تحرك في جعل جميع المستويات
وكلما وصلت لنا طلب اغاثه في الفورا
اما نتجه اليه برا اما بواسطه
الطرقات اما بواسطه الطائرات الهليكوبتر
حتى نمسح المنطقه كلها واعتقد ان منطقه
كلها تقريبا ونعرف انما اين وجدوا كنب هذه
الاستغاثات بالامس وبقيت في الانترنت
مثلا ساعطيك مثلا توفى حوالي 2122 شخص
الذي توفى بقيه فقط خمسين شخصا يتم دفنه
من هذه الفين شخص ونحن نحاول ان ننسانا
اليوم في المساء
وغدا حتى لا يبقى هناك اموال
ونحن نتابع هذه الصور لعمليات الانقاذ ما
هي ابرز التحديات التي تواجه رجال الانقاص
سيد الوزير
الطريق هذه اولا حتى لان هناك بعض الابيات
لا نستطيع ان ننقلها ننقلها مع ان ينقلها
الجيش والدفاع المدني ان يرقلها الى اماكن
الزلزال حتى يستعملونها فقط الوسائل
اليدويه والمسائل الغذائيه ولكن ما هو
ملاحظ هو ان بعض المناطق المواطنون انفسهم
من قاموا بهذه المهمه واجله جميع
المعطوبين والاموات وتمد دفنهم وهذا
التضامن المجتمعي كان
[موسيقى]
يسرنا كثيرا وفي الحقيقه انا اعيشها انا
حزين هذا المساء لان احد الذين اخرج اخيرا
من الركام كان فرحا وشكرنا وسلمت عليه
وحينما وصل المستشفى باللغه قبل ساعه انه
توفي رغم انه كان مسرورا
بانه
ساعيش حياه الاطول هل الادوات المتطوره
متوفره لرجال الانقاذ سيد الوزير سيد
الوزير
نعم متوفره وهناك اشياء وهناك وسائل جاءت
من الخارج من اسبانيا من قطر من دول من
الامارات من بريطانيا ولكن المشكل سيكون
في ايصالها الى اماكن
الاماكن الزلزال لهذا اتخذنا قرارا بانه
يجب ان تفسح الطرق كلها لدى الجيش ركز على
جميع الطرق لكن حينما ترى هذه الحجاره
اليوم خرجت الساعه الثانيه عشره بمنطقه
كانت نقطه اساسيه في الزلزال اسمها منطقه
وانا اراقب من بعيد وارى جبلا ينهار جزء
من جبل ينهار جزء كله والغبار في كل مكان
في الحقيقه هذه الصوره المخيفه طرحت
للسؤال هل يوجد بحث كره اخرى هل يوجد
مواطنون هل يوجد لذلك نلاحظ بانه ما زالت
اثار الجفاف تبدو على الطبيعه
تنهارون من بعض الجبال ومن بعض الاحجار
الكبيره التي تنهار والتي قد تهدد حياه
المواطنين هل ممكن تحديد فتره زمنيه
متوقعه لاكمال عمليه الاغاثه
غالبا سنكمل اليوم او غدا بالنسبه
للموجودين تحت الاروقات وللاموات لانه
هناك تصور وبرنامج عمل من اجل ايواء
وتوفير حياه احسن ونحن مقبلون على الشتاء
وفي هذه المناطق كون الجو باردا في بعض
الامطار هناك مناطق هناك تكون فيها الثلوج
ويجب ان نستعد في اسرع وقت ممكن لتوفير
لهم السكن والاقامه والطعام وهذه من
تعليمات جلاله الملك وقراراته يعني انها
تم بمواطنيه في اقرب وقت هذا نريد ان
نصارع الزمن لكي نوفر لهم هذه الشروط يعني
اذا نريد ان نفسر اكثر ماذا بعد الاعلان
عن وقف عمليات البحث والانقاذ ما الذي
يبدا بعدها
نحن لن نوقف الا اذا لم يكن هناك لانه
هناك اشاره لانه في جميع هذه القرى الناس
يعرفون بعضهم
البعضون فيما بينهم فهم يؤكدون وجود شخص
او من عدمه او غياب شخص او او
اختفاء شخص لذلك
سنستمر في المراقبه وسنستمر في البحث ثم
بعد ذلك نقوم بالبرنامج ايواء الاشخاص
فهناك قرى دمرت بكاملها ولم يعد لها وجود
فيجب ايواءهم تغفر لهم لكن ثم هناك مدارس
لم تعد لم تعد تستطيع ان تستقبل التلاميذ
ويجب على بناءها وتوفير الدراسه لهؤلاء
التلاميذ يجب ان نقلهم الى
استمرار الشفاء بالمستشفى وحينما يتمثل
لنا الشفاء لا يمكننا ان نخرجهم من
المستشفى لان ليست لهم منازل يعودون اليها
فيجب ايواءهم الى حين ان يتموا الى الشفاء
نهائيا هل اقل بهدف مثلا
بعض الفنادق لحتى ناوي فيها هؤلاء الجرحى
بل في وزاره العاده تملك مؤسستين للايوان
بالنسبه للقطل فوضعناهم اشاره وزاره الصحه
ما هي المعايير او الاسس التي تقرر على
اساسها او تقرر الحكومه على اساسها وقف
عمليه البحث والبدء في ما يسمى ببروتوكول
الاغاثه البدء بتامين الماوى والغذاء
والغذاء ومياه الشفا وما شابه
ومعيار واحد الا يصلهما خبر ان هناك شخص
موجود في مكان ما نتوقف حتى نتاكد بان ليس
هناك اي شخص تحت الارقام حتى ولو كان
سنستمر في البحث وسيستمر الجيش في العمل
هناك جيش عظيم يقوم بعمله وهناك مواطنين
عظام يقومون بعملهم هناك سلطات عموميه
تقوم بعملها فيجبال نستمر الى ان نتاكد
نهائيا انه ليس هناك شخص
فهمنا ان كل القطاعات في واضح فهمنا ان كل
القطاعات تقريبا في المغرب تساهم في عمليه
الاغاثه ماذا عن المجتمع المدني سيد
الوزير خاصه في المناطق التي كانت مقفله
امام
الاغاثه الحكوميه
تاكد بان مجتمع المدني في الحقيقه فاجاني
جدا على مستوى القرى يوجد المجتمع المدني
صغير كما بنفسه باخراج المعطوبين وباخراج
العالقين وبدفن
الاموات بل انه مثلا في الدار البيضاء
الشباب الصغار جمعوا كثير من الماء وجمعوا
كثيرا من الاكل وجواكت من الاطعمه وجمع
كثير من الاغطيه ويتصلون بيوميا يطلبون
بان يرسلونها الى مكان الزلزال في الحقيقه
ثم هناك جمعيات المعروفه
وفي الحقيقه
هذا التضامن الشعبي الكبير والذي سيبرز من
خلال المساهمه في الصندوق المالي الذي
اسسه جلاله الملك محمد السادس وهو الصندوق
رقم 126 الذي وضع رهن اشاره المغاربه
يساهم بمبال لفائده هؤلاء الاشخاص
ستلاحظون بانه المغاربه من صغارهم
سيساهمون في هذا المبلغ دائما هم يتصلون
بالهاتف ويسالونني هل كيف يمكنني كيف
يمكنني
الادويه كيف يمكن لدرجه ان بعض الطلبه
اتصلوا به وطلبوا ان يرتخي بمكان يعالج
الناس
اذا سمحت لي كيف تصف
التعاون الاقليمي والعربي والدولي مع هذه
الكارثه الانسانيه في المغرب كيف تصف
المساعدات
اكثر من 60 الى 70 دوله اعلنت استعدادها
لدعم المغرب ونحن فرحون جدا ونحترم فيهم
هذه هذا الاهتمام ونعتبره اشاره ايجابيه
لمكانه المغرب الاقليميه والدوليه على
مستوى الاقليمي جدول المحيطه كلها
لدعم المغرب على الدوله
لمختلف مكوناتها فقط نحن نريد ان ننظم
الامور وان نرتب الامور نريد اولا كل دوله
اقترحت اشياء تريد ان تدعم بها واقترحت
منتوجات اريد تقدمها لكن نريد ان نضبط
الامور وان ننظم الامور حتى يكون هناك
ضياع لهذه
العطاءات هذا تكون هناك فوضى
نحدد الاولويات والاحتياجات ثم دوله بدوله
فالان لما سالنا ما هي الاولويات قلنا لهم
الاولويات هو اخراج العالقين
والضحايا فورا الحكومه سمحت بدخول اربع
فرق من الخارج ثم سالونا مره ثانيه لهم
اعطيه والخيم فورا اتفقنا مع بعض الدول
نحن نسير خطوه بخطوه الامور فنحن دوله
ودوله منظمه ودوله مضبوطه ودوله لها عمل
ونريد وهذا التعاون الدوله نرفضه في جميع
الاحوال لانه يعبر عن حاله انسانيه يعبر
عن تضامن دولي ويعتصر ويؤكد على مكانه
المغرب على مستوى الدوله ونريد ان نحافظ
على هذه المكانه ونشكر هذه الدول جميعا
ونشكر كل من اتصل بالهاتف سواء
الاخرين او رئيس الحكومه هذه الاشاره كلها
سنحافظ عليها ولكن فقط نريد ان ننظم
الامور وان نضبط الامور وان نعطي
الاولويات حقها في الاولويه شكرا لك وزير
العدل المغربي عبد اللطيف وهبي في اكادير
اعلنت وزاره الداخليه المغربيه في بايرن
ان السلطات المغربيه استجابت في هذه
المرحله بالذات لعروض الدعم التي قدمتها
الدول الصديقه اسبانيا وقطر وبريطانيا
والامارات العربيه المتحده والتي اقترحت
تعبئه مجموعه من فرق البحث والانقاذ جاته
المغربيه ان السلطات المغربيه اجرت تقييما
دقيقا للاحتياجات في الميدان اخذه بعين
الاعتبار ان عدم التنسيق في مثل هذه
الحالات سيؤدي الى نتائج عكسيه
وقال الناطق باسم الحكومه ان رئيس الحكومه
سيتراس غدا الاثنين اللجنه المكلفه باعاده
بناء المناطق المتضرره وكان رئيس الحكومه
المغربيه قال ان حكمته شكلت خليه ازمه تحت
اشراف وزاره الداخليه بناء على توجيهات
العاهل المغربي وظفر رئيس الحكومه
المغربيه في حسابه على فيسبوك انه سيتواصل
اتخاذ التدابير التي باشرتها الحكومه
تنفيذا للتوجيهات الملكيه الراميه الى
متابعه ودعم جهود الاغاثه من اجل ضمان حسن
سير العمليات بحسب تعبيره
هذا واعلنا مصطفى بيت سناطق باسم الحكومه
المغربيه اصدار الحكومه مرسوما يخصص حسابا
يحمل اسم الصندوق الخاص بتدبير الاثار
المترتبه على الزلزال وقال ان الحساب
سيخصص لتلقي المساعدات التطوعيه التضامنيه
للهيئات الخاصه والعموميه وللمواطنين بشكل
اساسي لتحمل نفقات المختلفه لاعاده البناء
والتكفل بالمتضررين من الزلزال
برنامج الاستعجالي لاعاده تاهيل وتقديم
الدعم لاعاده بناء المنازل المدمره على
مستوى المناطق
المتضرره النفقات المتعلقه بالتكفل
بالاشخاص في وضعيه صعبه خصوصا اليتامى
والاشخاص في وضعيه هشه النفقات المتعلقه
بالتكفل الفوري بكافه الاشخاص بدون ماوى
جراء الزلزال لا سيما فيما يرتبط بالايواء
والتغذيه وكافه الاحتياجات الاساسيه
النفقات المتعلقه بتشجيع الفاعلين
الاقتصاديين بهدف الاستئناف الفوري
للانشطه على مستوى المناطق المعنيه
النفقات المتعلقه بتشكيل احتياطات ومخزون
للحاجيات الاوليه على مستوى كل جهه من
المملكه من اجل مواجهه كل اشكال الكوارث
جميع النفقات الاخرى المرتبطه بتدبير اثار
هذا الزلزال
تواصل مجموعه البحث والانقاذ القطريه
الدوليه ارسال معدات واليات متخصصه الى
المغرب بالاضافه الى نقل مساعدات انسانيه
عاجله للتخفيف من معاناه المتضررين عقب
زلزال الذي ضرب عده اقاليم مغربيه وكانت
الدفعه الاولى من المجموعه قد وصلت الى
المغرب في وقت سابق من اليوم للمساهمه في
عمليه البحث والانقاذ
وقد وصلت مجموعه البحث والانقاذ القطريه
الدوليه الى المغرب للمساهمه في عمليات
الاغاثه ودعم المتضررين من الزلزال وتشارك
المجموعه في عمليات البحث والانقاذ معززه
باليات ومعدات متخصصه بالاضافه الى
مساعدات انسانيه عاجله للتخفيف على
المتضررين من الزلزال
كما ارسلت اسبانيا فريقا من 56 مسعفا الى
المغرب لدعم السلطات المحليه في عمليه
البحث والانقاذ لضحايا الزلزال واقلعت
طائره عسكريه من قاعده شمالي اسبانيا
متوجهه الى مراكش تحمل على متنها قوات من
وحده الطوارئ العسكريه مكلفه بالمساعده في
جنود البحث والانقاط وكان وزير الخارجيه
الاسباني حسام نويل الباريس اعلن في وقت
سابق ان مدريد ستقدم مساعده بقدر ما يحتاج
اليه المغرب مع التركيز في البدايه على
انقاذ اكبر عدد ممكن من الضحايا ومتى حان
الوقت لاعاده الاعمار ستكون المساعده
الاسبانيه جاهزه ايضا
قالت وكاله الانباء السعوديه ان العاهل
السعوديه الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز وولي
العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
وجهابي تسيير جسر جوي لتقديم المساعدات
للمغرب وقال المستشار بالديوان الملكي عبد
الله الربيعه فريق بحث وانقاذ وفريقا من
هيئه الهلال الاحمر السعودي سيتوجهان الى
المغرب للمشاركه في الاعمال الاغاثيه
والانسانيه
واصدرت دول عديده في قمه العشرين ومنظمات
دوليه من بينها صندوق النقد الدولي بيانا
مشتركا للتضامن مع المغرب وفق البيان فقد
عبرت هذه الدول والمنظمات عن استعدادها
لتقديم كل الدعم اللازم لاي احتياجات
ماليه عاجله على المدى القصير ولجهود
اعاده الاعمار
اذا تركز الزلزال الذي ضرب المغرب في
دائره التاثر القصوى في مناطق يغلب عليها
الطابع الجبلي ما اوجد تحديات امام الفرق
الطبيه وفرق البحث والانقاذ التفاصيل
نتابعها في هذا التقرير
هو الزلزال الاقوى الذي يضرب المغرب منذ
ثلاثه قرون شدته ومركزه القريب من جبال
الاطلس حول الجغرافيا الى واحده من اكبر
التحديات امام فرق الانقاذ والبحر لكن
الاضرار والخسائر تفاوتت بين دائره التاثر
الاوسع التي وصلت الى مراكش واكادير
وقطرها 400 كيلو متر ومركز الزلزال في
اقليم الحوز بقطر ستين كيلو مترا تقريبا
وهو اقليم يغلب عليه الطابع الجبلي تغطي
الجبال ثلاثه ارباع مساحته فاتت الاضرار
في الحوض كبيره
الاقليم يضم نحو اربعين قريه ومدينه
وتجمعا سكانيا اغلبه مناطق وعيره ويسكنه
قرابه 600 الف نسمه تغلب الجبال على
تضاريس الحوز اذا وتعتبر قريه ايغيل على
هضبه محاطه بالجبال مركز الزلزال اما في
تارودانت فحجم الماساه كبير
تلتقي فيها سلسله جبال الاطلس الصغير
والاطلس الكبير تسببت الزلزال في حدوث
انهيارات صخريه في القرى الجبليه فدمر
بعضها بشكل شبه كامل
انهارت جل المباني الطينيه وتسببت الزلزال
في قطع الطرق بسبب الانهيارات الصخريه ما
ادى الى تعقيد عمليات الانقاذ
وتحولت بعض القرى النائيه الى اطلال بفعل
الدمار مع استمرار جهود الفرق الطبيه
للوصول
الى المناطق النائيه لحق الضرر مواقع
ثقافيه واثريه في تارودانت المدينه فالسور
التاريخي الاقدم في المغرب يحيط بها
وغالبيه سكانها يعيشون داخل اسوارها حتى
يومنا هذا
الى اقليم الشيشاوه اداسيل تحديدا قريه
جبليه سويت بالارض كليا يعتبر الاقليم
بموقعه الجغرافي ممرا ضروريا لمناطق جنوب
وغرب المغرب
فرحا حق نائب المتحدث باسم الامين العام
المتحده
كيف تقيمون الاستهجاب الدوليه للمساهمه في
التخفيف على المتضررين من زلزال المغرب
برؤيه مختلف اوجه التضامن من مختلف دول
العالم التضامن مع المملكه المغربيه ونحن
نرى بان الكثير من المساعدات تنتقل الى
المغرب من جانب الامم المتحده هناك فريق
التقييم والاستجابه للكوارث الطبيعيه وصل
هذا الطريق الى المغرب وهو يعمل على تنسيق
الجهود جهود الاغاثه بالنسبه للامم
المتحده لا تتوفر على الفريق للبحث
والانقاذ ولكن في السابق نحن ساعدنا في
هذا النوع من الكوارث ساعدنا فيه تنسيق
جهود الاغاثه والجهود الانقاذ ونحن سعداء
بمشاركه في هذا الجهد الدوري بشكل عام
اعتقد ان هناك الكثير من الجهد يتم القيام
به الان لكن هناك حاجه للمزيد من فرق
البحث والانقاذ هناك ضروره رفع الانقاذ
هناك ايضا حاجه لفرق طبيه وهناك حاجه
لتبرع بالدم الى جانب توفير الغداء
والدواء هل ممكن ان نعرف اكثر ما هي
منظمات الامم المتحده التي تشارك حاليا في
الاستجابه للاغاثه سيد فرحان حق
هذه المرحله والخطوه الاولى هي ايضا تقييم
الحاجيات
وجمع البيانات الضروريه وكما قلت من
الواضح ان ما هو ضروري الان الغذاء او
الدواء والماوى وبالتالي فريق المتحده
يعمل على تقييم الاحتياجات ونحن بحاجه
للتنسيق في هذا الخصوص مع الحكومه
المغربيه واعتقد ان الحكومه المغربيه قامت
بجهد جباره لتقديم العون للمحتاجين
والمتضررين ونحن نعمل على تقديم المزيد من
العون وما التحديات بتقييمكم لتقديم العون
سواء كان الدوله او حتى من الامم المتحده
لمساهمه في التخفيف عن المتضررين
بالنسبه للمتحده بامكانها ان تقوم باعمال
اخرى من قبيل التزويد المحتاجين بالماء
والدواء
والمهمه الاساسيه الان في هذا النوع من
الكوارث الطبيعيه والاماكن المتضرره نعرف
ان المغرب بحاجه الى فرق
انقاذ والبحث نحن نتوفر على هذا النوع من
الفرق لكن يمكن ان ننسق اعمال البحث
لانقاذ في هذا التصويت اعلمنا ان فريقا من
يونسكو سيتوجه للمغرب للوقوف على الاثار
التي تضررت جراء هذا الزلزال ما الذي
تخبرنا في هذا الجانب
هذا صحيح
وهذا عمل
قيم جدا بالنسبه لهذه المنظمه التابعه
للامم المتحده في مدينه مراكش ال يونس
ستحل بمراكش بفريق من الخبراء لتقييم
الاضرار التي حلت
بالاماكن التاريخيه والماثر التاريخيه
الموجوده بمدينه مراكش شكرا لك فرحان حق
نائب المتحدث باسم الامين العام الامم
المتحده في نيويورك
وقد اعتبر خبراء الزلزال ان درجه الزلزال
الذي ضرب مناطق في المغرب قبل يومين لافته
ويقول العلماء انه كان من المستحيل التنبؤ
بمثل زلزال اقليم الحوز وبالقوه التي وصل
اليها التقرير التالي يوضح الاسباب التي
جعلت وقوع الزلزال حدثا مفاجئا بالنسبه
لعلماء الجيولوجيا
في الذاكره الحيه لم يسبق ان شهد المغرب
مثل قوه زلزال الثامن من سبتمبر تعادل قوه
الزلزال 25 قنبله نوويه انها مفاجاه
حقيقيه ستعيد لا محاله خلط الاوراق امام
العلماء هذا ما يقوله خبراء الزلازل لكن
لماذا كل هذه الحيره
مسلمات الجيولوجيا هي منبع هذه الحيره
تحدث الزلازل في المناطق الواقعه عند
الحدود الفاصله بين الصفائح التكتونيه
فاليابان واندونيسيا وتركيا وايطاليا
واليونان مناطق ناشطه زلزاليا في شمال
افريقيا تقع المغرب مثل الجزائر وتونس
اقصى شمال الصفيحه التكتونيه الافريقيه
تتقابل الصفيحه الافريقيه مع الصفيحه
الاوروسيه والتي تضم اوروبا واسيا معا
باستثناء شبه القاره الهنديه وشبه الجزيره
العربيه
تغوص الصفيحه الافريقيه اسفل الصفيحه
الاوراسيه فنجد ان مناطق اليونان وقبرص
والدول المطله على البحر المتوسط تشهد
وقوع العديد من الزلازل بين الفينه
والاخرى تمر منطقه الاتصال بين الصفيحتين
الاوراسيه والافريقيه بشمال المغرب
والجزائر لذلك من الطبيعي جدا حدوث
الزلازل في المدن التي تقع عند الحد
الفاصل بين الصفيحتين التكتونيتين لكن
بشكل عام تقع منطقه المغرب العربي في
منطقه زلزاليه متوسطه وفقا للسجل
الجيولوجي فان الجزائر هي الاكثر نشاطا في
حين توصف تونس بانها الاقل تاتي المغرب في
وضع متوسط ذلك انها تتحرك مع كتله جبال
الاطلس
ففي عام 1960 هز زلزال مدينه اغادير واوده
بحياه اكثر من 12 الف شخص لم تكن قوه
الزلزال كبيره لكن مركزه كان اسفل مدينه
اغادير مباشره وفي عام
1980 تسبب زلزال في ولايه الشلف الاصنام
سابقا في شمال الجزائر في مقتل اكثر من
خمسه الاف شخص وبقوه سبع درجات وثلاثه
اعشار ويعتبر الاقوى في غرب البحر الابيض
المتوسط حتى الان وفي شمال الجزائر ايضا
ضرب زلزال عام 2003 منطقه بومرداس وبلغت
قوته 6 درجات وثمانيه اعشار واوقع
2266 قتيلا لكن خصوصيه زلزال الثامن من
سبتمبر والمفاجئ في هذه المره انه حدث
داخل صفيحه التكتونيه وليس عند اطرافها او
حدودها مع صفيحه اخرى فوفقا لهيئه المسح
الجيولوجي الامري فان مركز الزلزال كان
قرب بلده ايغيل في اقليم الحوز على بعد 71
كيلو مترا جنوب غربي مراكش وعلى عمق 18
كيلو مترا ونصف فاقليم الحوز الذي كان
الاكثر تضررا يبعد عن حد التصادم بين
صفيحه الافريقيه والاوروسيه بنحو 500
كيلومتر الى الجنوب منها وبالتالي كان
العلماء يستبعدون حدوث زلازل بهذه القوه
في تلك المنطقه لم يشهد المغرب زلزالا
بهذه القوه منذ 100 عام على الاقل بل يقول
العلماء انه كان من المستحيل التنبؤ بمثل
زلزال اقليم الحوز فالحركه في المناطق
البعيده عن حدود الصفائح بطيئه للغايه
وغير قادره على توليد زلزال بمثل هذه
القوه لكن من الواضح ان زلزال المغرب
سيغير الكثير من النظريات لدى علماء
الزلازل والجيولوجيا
البروفيسور نجيب ابو كركي استاذ علم
الزلزال في الجامعه الاردنيه انضم الينا
من عمان بروفيسور زلزال بقوته لافت ومفاجئ
في هذه المنطقه الى ماذا يؤشر هذا
في الواقع المفاجئ لماذا يعني مفاجئ لاننا
نسينا ان هذه المنطقه هي منطقه زلزاليه
ربما انه مرت فتره طويله عن اخر زلزال حصل
في هذه المنطقه
ربما انه لا يوجد ما يكفي من دراسات تنقيب
عن زلازل ما قبل التاريخ في هذه المنطقه
الزلازل في الوا
قع لسرعتها وما شابه ذلك يختلف عن النمط
الانساني والسرعه الانسانيه لذلك يعني
نتفاجئ بهذا لاننا الى حد ما وهذا من سمات
المناطق التي تقوم بها الزلازل المتباعده
يعني يميل الانسان عمليا اذا التفاؤل
المفرط احيانا ولكن يفاجئ بهكذا زلازل
وهذا سيحصل مستقبلا يعني في كل المناطق
المشابهه لهذه المنطقه بروفيسور ما
العوامل التي اجتمعت لتجعل زلزال المغرب
مدمرا بهذا الشكل
يعني واضح تماما انه الموقع الجغرافي
الكون المنطقه جبليه وعره كونه ايضا
البناء الى حد ما تقليدي بدون اسمنت مسلح
وامور من هذا القبيل اعطيني يعني معروف
عمليا بانه لا يقاوم القص يعني اذا كان في
عندي جدار طيني
ودفعته
ينقص وينقص عمليا بعكس لو كان من الاسمنت
المسلح سيكون هنالك نوع من انواع المقاومه
ايضا الخسائر كبيره لانه ايضا حصل ليلا
عمليا يعني معظم الناس في تلك في ذلك
الوقت يعني في المنازل غالبا يعني
ادت الى هذا بالاضافه الى انه يعني الفتره
الزمنيه الطويله عن الزلزال السابق في هذه
المنطقه تعني ان هذه المنطقه قد راقت قد
راكمت ضغوط بما يكفي لكي تنتج زلزال بهذه
القوه البروفيسور تبعنا مع مراسلين قبل
قليل بان
الناس في في المغرب خاصه في المناطق
المتضرره تخاف لذلك هي تفتش العراء من مما
يعرف بها الذات ارتداديه هل هل ما زال
الاحتمال قائما لهزات ارتداديه وهل من
الممكن التنبؤ او توقع قوه هذه الهزات
الارتذاذيه
في الواقع الاحتمال قائم
ويعني بوارق الامل في هذا المجال انه
الزلازل من هذا النوع يعني تميل الى انها
تتناقص مع الزمن وتتناقص قوتها ولكن للاسف
الشديد انها بتكون برضو بدون انتظام مما
يعني امكانيه حصول مفاجات فبعد يومين من
الزلزال لا يمكن ان نقول بانه لا يوجد
احتماليه
لهزات ارتداديه هذه الاحتماليه ستبقى
واحده وما يحدد
نقطه الامان الى حد ما ولو النسبي هي
متابعه الرصد الزلزالي ومراقبه كيف تضمحل
هذه
الاحداث الزلزاليه وفيما اذا كان يعني
التوجه هو توجه نحو الاستقرار ام لا
بمتابعتك للاحداث بما يعرف ببروتوكول
الزلازل والاغاثه من الزلازل في اي مرحله
نحن الان من زلزال المغرب بتوقعاتك
يعني حاليا ربما هي
الصدمه الاولى مرت
والان نحن في مرحله محاوله يعني انقاذ ما
يمكن انقاذه
اعن الله يعني الذين يقومون على هذا الوضع
ليس سهلا خصوصا لانه في هنالك تعقيدات
لوجستيه والمنطقه كما نلاحظ جبليه الطرق
معقده
لكن برضو في بعض النواحي الايجابيه انه
الجو عمليا يعني جيد ولا يضر الناس انهم
يكونوا يعني في العراء لفتره معينه بعكس
ما لو كان الوقت شتاء في مناطق ثلجيه مثلا
او هذا يعني هكذا امور
وايضا على
وزير العدل قبل قليل قال بان الحكومه
مستمره في البحث عن ناجين علميا
متى يصبح من الصعب الوصول الى ناجين جراء
هذا زلزال مدمر باقتضاب لو سمحت
اول حقيقه يعني في بعض الزلازل وجد ناجين
بعد 11 يوم من الكارثه بشكل واضح يعني
وبرضو في تركيا هنالك يعني تم اختراق هذا
الرقم
وجدنا ناس ناجين ايضا بعد فتره اطول من
هذا يعني بعد اسبوعين او اكثر فهذا في
الواقع يعني قرار
يعني حكومي يترك لهم شكرا ولكن في الواقع
يعني يجب عدم
الياس من هذا الموضوع المساله تصير
في النها
يه الى حد ما شكرا لك البروفيسور نجيب ابو
كركي استاذ علم الزلازل في الجامعه
الاردنيه في عمان شكرا لك
هذا وتتجه كذلك الجهود الى تقييم الاضرار
في مباني تاريخيه تمثل جانبا من التراث
الاثري المغربي خاصه في المدينه القديمه
بمراكش او في اقليم الحوز وضع وضع دفع
يونسكو الى التحرك للمساعده على حصر
الاضرار ومتابعه ترميم وانقاذ هذه المواقع
ثالث اكبر مدينه في المملكه المغربيه من
حيث عدد السكان تاسست في القرن الثاني عشر
وبنى فيها المرابطون العديد من المعالم
التاريخيه
ادرجت مدينه مراكش في قوائم اليونسكو
للتراث العالمي واعطت الجدران الحمراء
للمدينه ومختلف المباني التي شيدت من
الحجر الرملي الاحمر لقب المدينه الحمراء
لكن وضع المدينه انقلب مع زلزال بقوه نحو
سبع درجات على سلم الاختر كان مركزه في
اقليم الحوز المجاور بمثل ما تضررت بسببه
مبان ومنشات فقد كانت المواقع والمعالم
الاثريه عرضه كذلك لاضرار جغرافيا تقع
مراكش على بعد نحو 327 كيلومترا جنوب شرق
العاصمه المغربيه الرباط ومن معالمها التي
تضررت هيكل ماجد الكتبيه التاريخي ويعود
تاريخه الى القرن الثاني عشر وتعرف مئذنته
التي يبلغ ارتفاعها 69 مترا باسم سقف مرا
ولم يتضح حجم الاضرار التي لحقت به
المدينه القديمه لمراكش والتي يطلق عليها
اسم المدينه العتيقه تعرضت بدورها لاضرار
بالغه بسبب الزلزال بنيت بين عامي 71 و72
كعاصمه لدوله المرابطيه ثم للدوله
الموحديه وتضم مجموعه من الاثار وتميزها
اسورها وابوابها وكذلك المنازل التقليديه
القديمه من رياضات وغيرها بطبع مغربي قديم
متميز وقد سجلت عام 85 ضمن قائمه التراث
العالمي لليونسكو كما نشر مغاربه مقاطع
فيديو تظهر تضرر اجزاء من اسوار مراكش
الدفاعيه التاريخيه التي شيدت لاول مره في
مطلع القرن الثاني عشر وهي عباره عن جدران
ترابيه حمراء تحيط بوسط المدينه القديمه
ومدرجه على لائحه اليونسكو للتراث العالمي
على مسافه 19 كلم حول المدينه ويصل
ارتفاعها الى 19 قدما ولديها 20 بوابه و
100 برج على طولها اما في ساحه جامع
الفناء التي يرجع تاريخها الى عهد تاسيس
مدينه مراكش ويقترن بها فقد انهارت صومعه
ماجد خربوش وتضررت المحل التجاريه لصناع
التقليديين بالسوق المجاور من المعالم
التي لم تسلم من الزلزال ماجد تيمال او
المسجد الاعظم الذي يقع في اقليم الحوز
الذي يعد مركز الزلزال هو مجد تاريخي بني
في عهد الخليفه عبد المؤمن بن علي الموحدي
حوالي
1153 ميلاديه وتعرض لاضرار كبيره بسبب
الزلزال
وتفاعلا مع تعرض هذه المعالم وغيرها
للاضرار والدمار قالت المديره العامه
لليونسكو ادريس انها توجهت مع بعثه من
اليونسكو لمدينه مراكش لدعم السلطات
المغربيه في حصر الاضرار والعمل على اعاده
الاعمار
[موسيقى]
اذا مستمرون معكم في هذه التغطيه لزلزال
المغرب المدمر اذكركم بابرز العناوين
في ثالث يوم على زلزال المغرب فرق الانقاذ
تسابق الزمن للوصول الى ناجين وسط صعوبات
في المناطق الجبليه والنائيه القوات
المسلحه المغربيه تدفع بتعزيزات لدعم
عمليات الانقاذ في اكثر المناطق تضررا
بمركز الزلزال وفرق انقاذ عربيه ودوليه
تتوجه للمساهمه في الاغاثه
الضحايا يتجاوزون 2100 قتيل معظمهم في
اقليم الحوز جنوب مراكش تشكيل خليه ازمه
حكوميه لتنسيق التدخلات والجزيره ترصد
عمليات البحث ورفع الانقاض في منطقه مركز
الزلزال
الاف يبتون في العراء وسط مخاوف من هزات
ارتداديه الصليب الاحمر ينبه الى ان
احتواء اثار الكارثه اجتماعيا واقتصاديا
قد يتطلب سنوات ويونسكو ترسل بعثه للمغرب
للوقوف على المعالم الاثريه المتضرره
تجاره الزلزال
[موسيقى]
تستمر جهود البحث عن ناجينا من زلزال
المغرب في اليوم الثالث بعد وقوع الكارثه
اخر الارقام بحسب الداخليه المغربيه تقول
ان عدد الضحايا ارتفع الى
2122 قتيلا بينما بلغ عدد المصابين
2421 واعلنت الحكومه المغربيه انشاء خليه
ازمه تحت اشراف وزاره الداخليه لمتابعه
ودعم جهود الاغاثه وضمان حسن سير عمليات
الانقاذ مباشره الى شبكه مراسلين من مركز
الزلزال في اقليم الحوز المختار العلاوي
من اقليم ازيلال سيف الدين بوعلاق ومن
مراكش سعيد بوخفه المختار العلاوي ابدا
معك المزالات هناك مناطق معزوله في قرى
مكان وقوع سلسال
نعم جلال قبل قليل من هذا المكان الذي
نتواجد فيه راينا
اليه كبيره متخصصه في فتح الطرق مرت من
هذا الجانب وسالت القائمين عليها قالوا لي
ان لقد بالفعل نجحنا في فتح الطريق المؤدي
الى احد الدواوير القريبه من هذه المنطقه
التي نتواجد فيها بلده امزميز في اقليم
الحوز لكن لا تزال قرى اخرى معزوله بالنظر
الى قوه الزلزال من جهه بالنظر الى انها
قوه الزلزال كانت في منطقه جبليه وكانت
هناك انهيارات تشققات لبعض الجبال وسقوط
كتل صخريه كبيره اعاقه
ومنعت ان تكون هذه الطرق مفتوحه ولهذا
فقامت القوات المسلحه الملكيه
اليوم بارسال تعزيزات تهدف بالاساس الى
فتح هذه الطرق الجبليه الوعره بعضها معبد
بعضها غير معبد هناك بعض الدواوير طرقها
ضيقه لا تصلح للسيارات تصلح فقط للدراجات
والبغال وما الى ذلك وهذا الوضع اعاقه
الوصول الى تلك الدواوير النائيه سمعنا
شهادات
روت يعني جوانب صعبه حيث ان المعاناه في
تلك المناطق الكبيره الناس تحتاج الى
مجموعه من المواد الاساسيه رغم حمله
التضامن الكبيره التي رايناها في على سبيل
المثال سكان مجموعه من المدن القريبه وحتى
البعيده جاءوا خلال الساعات الماضيه بما
توفر من مساعدات من اغذيه لتقديمها وكانت
حركه السير مزدحمه خلال الساعات الماضيه
الان بعد اليوم تميز في كانت فيه درجه
الحراره مرتفعه بدات درجه الحراره تدريجيا
تنخفض وتتجه نحو البروده ايضا مع يعني
دخلنا عمليا ساعات الليل بعد الاسر
المغربيه المتواجده هنا تركت منازلها
المهدده
بالسقوط كما نشاهد
سكنوا او استقروا مؤقتا في سياراتهم
وتركوا منازلهم المهدده بالسقوط في اجراء
احتياطي اجراء احتياطي بالنظر الى الهزات
الارتداديه التي تعرفها المنطقه والتي
حدوثها خلال الساعات القادمه اذا قدر الله
او الايام القادمه سيتسبب في تعميق
الماساه وسيتسبب في تواجه لانه لدينا في
هذه المناطق اعداد كبيره من المنازل
المهدده بالسقوط لدينا سقطت واخرى منازل
مهدده بالسقوط بالاضافه الى السيارات
لدينا في هذه الجهه وايضا في تلك الجهه
خيمات خيمات بعضها انشاته وزاره الداخليه
تحديدا الدفاع المدني يمكن ان نقترب اكثر
لننقل جانب من الصوره الى المشاهدين هذه
الخيمات انشاتها انشاها الدفاع المدني
لهذه الاسر التي منازلها اما سقطت كليا او
مهدده بالسقوط من اجل حمايتهم لانه كانت
هناك توجيهات من السلطات بعدم دخول تلك
المنازل والابتعاد عنها تجنبا لوقوع ماسي
وضحايا جدد هذا هو الواقع الان هنا في امس
ميز في
اقليم الحوز المغربي حيث نشاهد ان الاسره
المغربيه باطفالها بنسائها
التجاوا الى هذه الخيام وحمايه
والتزاما ايضا بالتوجيهات في ظل
ارتفاع المخاطر وايضا راينا خلال ساعات
الماضيه انه فرقه الانقاذ عملت على انقاذ
مجموعه من الضحايا بالنظر الى ان المنطقه
منطقه جبليه تصعب فيها الحركه في ظل اغلاق
الطرق وما الى ذلك ايضا بالاضافه الى
عمليات الانقاذ وايضا عمليات النزوح نحو
هذه الخيام بشكل مؤقت هناك عمليات تضامن
وهناك ايضا
يعني سيارات جاءت من المناطق الاخرى
لتقديم
اليد العون الى هؤلاء السكان مع العلم انه
فرق الانقاذ تبدو الجهودا كبيره وهي تصارع
الزمن حيث ان اليوم هذه اليوم بالتحديد
الليله الليله الثالثه
سندخل اليوم الرابع بالتالي
تتراجع فرص انقاذ المزيد من الضحايا ولكن
دائما هناك تشبث بالامل راينا على مدار
اليوم سيارات الاسعاف تهرب بسرعه كبيره في
اشاره وفخمه نقلته عناصر في الدفاع المدني
وايضا شهود عيان عن نجاح في عمليات انقاذ
واخراج بعض الضحايا منهم من هو على قيد
الحياه ومنهم من هو فارق الحياه شاهد خلال
ساعات الصباح الاولى امراه نقلت او نجحت
فرق الانقاذ في اخراجها لكنها توفيت في
سياره الاسعاف اثناء عمليه نقلها الى
المستشفى اذا هذا هو جانب من الصوره هنا
في اقليم الحوز الذي يمتد على مساحه
6200 كيلومتر مربع هذا الاقليم يتميز عن
غيره بانه اقليم جبلي معظم تضاري سه جبليه
وهو بؤره الزلزال الذي شهده المغرب قبل
ثلاثه سنوات اليك المختار في قرى مركز
الزلزال سعيد مخففه في مراكش سعيد كيف
يمضي اهل وسكان مراكش ليلتهم الثالثه
بعض في حتى في عشائهم اليوم قرروا ان يكون
عشاؤهم مجموعه كامله ربما ساضطر للحديث
باللهجه المغربيه حتى تفهمني السيده التي
تجهز الان عشاء لعائلتها وعائلات وجيرانها
اليوم
انتما قلت لي قبل قليل انكم لا تستطيعون
ما تقدروش تجلسوا في الديار لانهم مشققين
الدار من الفوق
وهذه الجيران حتى كنخافوا من الزلزال
واحنا مضامنين مع بعضياتنا هادو عائله
ديالي وجيراني وكل شيء ببنتي وكل شيء
وعائلتي وهذا نسيبي رجل بنتي
وكلشي كلشي كلشي
الكارثه من عند الله تعالى الله يجعل
مولانا
حتى احنا الله يجعل مولانا ييسر له الامر
باش يشوف من حال هذا المنكوبين تنطلبها من
الله عز وجل الله يجعل مولانا يشوف من
حالنا وحال المسلمين اجمعين اذا كتجمعوا
بيناتكم شويه ديال الفلوس وكاتجي
وكاتديروا عشاء اللي كتجمعوا فيه كاع
الناس وكتعشى فطور
[موسيقى]
هنايا ولا غادي
كاين شي احد اللي غادي يساعدكم مثلا ولا
جا عندكم
باش يقول لكم غادي نصاوبوا لكم الدار ولا
نتمنى لكم عشاء طيبا واذا ساعود اليك اذا
هذه هي حال العائلات هنا هناك تضامن شعبي
غير مسبوق بين الناس هم من ينظمون الناس
من لديه اي خبره في اي مجال يحاول ان
يساعد
بما يقدر عليه فلذلك مثلا هذه السيده التي
تحدثنا اليها للتو هي تستطيع كميات كبيره
من الطعام
لعائلتها وجيرانها ولذلك
يتعاونون بهذا الشكل ربما للتغلب على
الليالي القادمه لانهم كما قالت السيده
يخشون من الارتدادات الان اصبحت الخشيه
اكثر من الهزات الارتداديه اليوم كانت
هناك هزه تقريبا شعر بها كل سكان مراكش
كانت تقريبا اربعه وسته اعشار الدرجه من
على سلم فالناس لا زالوا لا يثقون في
العوده الى بيوتهم ويفضلون البقاء في
اماكن مفتوحه
مثلا في هذه الساحه في سيدي يوسف حيث
يجتمعون هناك خيم كثيره ليست فقط هذه
الخيمه هناك خيام كثيره في عائلات فيها
اطفال حتى الاطفال شكرا لك سعيد عدم ذهاب
شكرا سعيد ولشبكه مراسلينا ساعود اليكم
الان ينضم الينا من الرباط السيد مصطفى
بيتاس الناطق الرسمي باسم الحكومه
المغربيه سيد مصطفى الى اين وصلت جهود
الاغاثه والدعم والبحث عن مفقودين حتى
الان
الجهود مكثفه منذ تم منذ ان تم الاعلان عن
هذا الزلزال الذي اصاب بلادنا ومنذ ان
اصدر جلاله الملك تعليماته الساميه
للحكومه ولمكتلف المتدخلين سواء كانوا
مصالح مدنيه او عسكريه او طبيه او صحيه او
سلطات عموميه كل التعبئه كل تعبئه لكل
مختلف هذه المؤسسات ومختلف هذه المصالح
اليوم في الميدان في المناطق المتضرره
والهدف هو طبعا الوصول الى جميع المتضررين
الى الى انتشال جميع الجثانين وايضا
لتقديم المساعده والمعونه لكل هؤلاء
المتضررين والعلاج للمصابين العمل على قدم
الوثاق في مختلف المناطق بقيت بعض
الدواوير على مستوى بعض الجماعات يتم الان
العمل بشكل مكثف وسريع من اجل ان يتم
الوصول اليهم قريبا جدا ومن اجل ان يتم
الوقوف عند مختلف هذه الاضرار بشكل كامل
اين تقع هذه الدواوير تحديدا سيد مصطفى
بقيت بعض الدوا
وير
على مستوى الحوز وكل الجهود الان مختلف
يعني الامكانيات المتوفره لدى الحكومه ولد
الدوله وايضا مجموعه من الدول التي التحقت
خاصه الفرق الاسعاف التي التحقت ببلادنا
مشكوره كلها الان تشتغل في هذا الاطار
وبهدف واحد هو الوصول الى مختلف هؤلاء
المتضررين والمصابين والانتشار
الجثمين فالعمل كله الان ينصب على المجال
الميداني والتعبئه على اقصى وعلى اعلى
مستوى لكي يتم يعني الانتهاء من هذه
المرحله الاولى والانتقال الى مرحله ثانيه
مرحله البناء مرحله الاعمار مرحله يعني
معالجه كل هذه الاضرار على المستوى
الاقتصادي وايضا في خضم هذا المجهود الذي
تقوم به الحكومه الان على مستوى الجانب
الصحي بتنسيق كامل مع المصالح العسكريه
الصحيه هناك دعم نفسيه ايضا يقدم لهؤلاء
المتضر ايضا هناك تخصصات محدده مطلوبه
خاصه في مجال الكسور لغيرها عدد كبير من
الاطباء والممرضين
والسيارات الاسعاف مئات سيارات الاسعاف
وايضا كل الامكانيات متعبئه على مستوى هذه
المنطقه لكي يتم كما قلت الانتهاء من هذه
المرحله والانتقاليه الى المرحله الثانيه
التي اعطى فيها جلاله الملك توجيهاته
الساميه للاشتغال حول التطور من اجل اعاده
البناء الحكومه اشتغلت اليوم كان هناك
اليوم اجتماع لمجلس الحكومه تمت فيه
المصادقه على مرسوم من اجل احداث حساب
مرصد لهذا الموضوع غدا هناك اجتماع اخر
سوف يتراس السيد رئيس الحكومه هناك عمل
على المستوى الميدان هناك اجتماعات في
مختلف يعني الاماكن والغايه والهدف طبعا
هو الوصول ومن اجل تطويقي هاته الازمه
ونتمنى ان شاء الله قريبا جدا ان نقدم
مختلف هذه الافادات حول الوضع الميدانيا
سيد مصطفى متى تتوقعون الانت هاء من ما
سميتها المرحله الاولى وما هي ابرز
التحديات التي تواجهكم للانتهاء منها
التحديات هي بالاساس هي تساقط بعض الصخور
والتي تغلق بعض المنافذ والطرق لكن يتم
الاستعانه بالطائرات بالمروحيات للوصول
الى الدواوير وتقديم المساعده والمؤونه
لكن كما قلت للانتهاء من هذه المرحله
الاولى هناك عمل كبير نقوم به على مستوى
الميدان وعلى المستوى الواقع هناك تعبئه
كبيره هناك سلطات نتمنى نتمنى يعني ان
ننتهي من هذه المرحله قريبا جدا لكي ننتقل
لكي ننتقل الى المرحله الثانيه المتعلقه
باعاده الاعمار وما المعيار او الاساس
الذي على اساسه ستنتقلون الى الى ما
تسميها مرحله ثانيه سيد مصطفى هو المرحله
الثانيه
لماذا اردت ان اقسم بين هذين المستويين
لان الاولويه الاولى التي تشتغل عليها
الحكومه الان هي الوصول الى الى المتضررين
الى الوصول الى الى الى الى الى المصابين
الى الوصول الى من يعني
محاصر في منطقه لتقديم العلاج لتقديم
المساعده لتقديم الموكبه العمل الاخر هناك
فرق متخصصه تشتغل عليه خاصه هذا العمل
ديال اعاده الاعمار ديال اعاده البناء
ديال الاهتمام باليتامى ديال اعاده الحياه
الطبيعيه الى مجراهات طبيعي في هذه
الاقاليم كالتعليم والمدارس الى غيرها من
مختلف الخدمات الاجتماعيه التي تقدمها
الحكومه والدوله عموما فهناك عمل كبير
الان وتركيز كبير وشديد على على الاغاثه
على تقديم المساعده على تقديم المعونه على
الوقوف الى جانب الساكنه على فتح هذه
الطرق وهذه المنافذ التي اغلقت بفضل بفعل
هذه الصخور وبفضل الانهيارات السحريه التي
وقعت في هذه المنطقه فهناك تركيز كبير على
هذا الموضوع لكن في نفس الوقت نحن نفكر في
الجانب المرتبط باعاده البناء خاصه ان
جلاله الملك قدمت جهته الساميه والواضحه
والحكومه الان في مجال تفعيلها
سيد مصطفى تسمعني
هل لديكم يعني عدد تقديري لمن هم تحت
الانقاط حتى الان
يصعب ان نقدم ارقام حول
الاشخاص الموجودين تحت الانقاض لكن لكن
انا استطيع ان اؤكد لك بان باننا في
القريب العاجل سوف تستقر هذه الارقام خاصه
المتعلقه بالمرضى والمصابين والموتى لماذا
لان طبيعه المنطقه وطبيعه البنايات
الموجوده في المنطقه ليست يعني بنايات
مرتفعه وشاهقه هذا كلهم مناطق تقريبا كلها
جماعات توجد في العالم القروي والطبيعه
البنائيه هو بناء منخفض
فكل التركيز الان كل التركيز كما قلت هو
على الاغاثه على المساعده على الدعم على
العلاج ثم بعد ذلك سوف على راس كل يعني
ساعات سوف نقدم معطيات حول الحصيله التي
يعني نقف عليها الى جانب جهودكم في عمليه
البحث والانقاذ هناك ايضا تحديات فيما
يتعلق بتامين الغذاء والدواء والشرب
والكهرباء وما شابه ماذا تخبرنا عن هذا
الجانب
نعم هناك كبيره في هذا المجال لانه اليوم
يتم التكفل بكل هؤلاء طبقا لتوجيهات جلاله
الملك في هذا الموضوع يتم التكفل بالماكل
وبالمشرب وبالماوى وايضا هناك تعليمات
وتوجيهات صارمه وواضحه في مجال التكفل
باليتامى خاصه في وضعيات هشه يتم تعبئه كل
الامكانيات الدوله لابد ان نحيي مره اخرى
العمل الذي يقوم بها ايضا المجتمع المدني
الروح التضامن التي عبر عليها المواطن
المغاربه من مختلف المناطق وايضا لابد ان
اشكر الدول كما عبر عنه بلاغ الدول الملكي
والذي شكر الدول الشقيقه والصديقه والتي
يعني عبرت عن تضامنها مع المغرب فكل هذه
الجهود والامكانيات هي معباه على اعلى
مستوى ويتم العمل على يعني وضع كل هذه
الامكانيات رهن اشاره المواطنين جميع
الاليات التي موجوده لدى الحكومه خاصه
وزاره التجهيز تم وضعها في هذه الاقاليم
لتسريع هذا لتسريع فتح كل هذه الممر
والمعابر والطرق جميع الاطباء تقريبا
حوالي ازيد من الف طبيب ازيد من 1500 ممرض
جميع المستشفيات تم تعبئتها مئات سيارات
الاسعاف كل الامكانيات التخصصات المطلوبه
خاصه في الاصابات والكسور هناك تعبئه على
اعلى مستوى ويتم التفاعل والاستجابه
للمتطلبات التي يعبر عنها المسعفون التي
يعبر عنها رجال موجودون في ارض الميدان
لكي يعني يتم تقديم كل الدعم والمواكبه
بشكل سريع ذكرت طبعا الدعم الدولي كيف
يترجم هذا الدعم الاقليمي والعربي والدولي
على الارض حتى الساعه سيد مصطفى
هناك دعم كبير جدا هناك دول كثيره جدا
ومنظمات اقليميه ودوليه عبرت عن رغبتها في
مساعده المملكه المغربيه جلاله الملك
والدول وبلاغ الدوال الملكي عبر عن شكره
لكله لكل هؤلاء الذين عبروا عن عن تضامنهم
وعن مساعدتهم للمملكه المغربيه لكن اليوم
يتم
يعني الاستماع اكثر الى الميدان يتم
استماع اكثر الى المناطق المتضرره حاجاتهم
بشكل دقيق حيث يتم تعبئه كل الامكانيات
الموجوده وطنيا ومحليا ويتم طبعا
الاستعانه بكل الامكانيات التي تعرض والتي
عبر المسعفون المتدخلون ميدانيا عن الحاجه
اليها وفي مستوى اخر سوف يتم تحديد يعني
بناء على الاجتماعات التي سوف تعقد في
الغد يعني على الحاجيات المرتبطه بالبنائي
واعاده يعني بناء كل هذه الدور والمؤسسات
وسوف يكون يعني مستوى اخر من الحديث حول
هذه المساعدات شكرا لك
السيد مصطفى بيتاس الناطق الرسمي باسم
الحكومه المغربيه في الرباط
اذا نعود الى شبكه مراسلينا سيف الدين
بوعلاق موجود في اقليم ازيلال سيف الدين
الى اين وصلت جهود الاغاثه وتقديم الدعم
للمتضررين
نعم جلال في الحقيقه نحن الان في اقليم
ازيلال نزلنا من اعلى الجبل الان ونحن في
منتصف الطريق في هذه المنطقه الجبليه في
منطقه او في قريه
شاهدنا
جميع القصص والحكايه والالام والمعاناه في
اعين وفي ايضا في تجارب الشخصيه التي
عاشها اهالي تلك المنطقه في الجبل حيث
تقريبا قضينا معهم يوما كاملا وتحدثوا
الينا عن مشاكلهم وعن معاناتهم وعن
احبائهم الذين فقدوهم في هذه الحادثه
تقريبا وفق جهاز الدفاع الدرك الملكي يقول
ان العدد بلغ 11 شخصا في هذه القريه
النائيه تخيل جلال هذه المنطقه قريه تفرين
تبعد عن مركز الزلزال 300 كيلومتر 300 كم
عن الزلزال اغلب المنازل هدمت بالكامل بعض
المنازل ربما تضررت جزئيا او بشكل ضعيف
ولكن اغلب المنازل هدمت بشكل كامل بالنظر
طبعا الى طبيعه المنطقه الجبليه الواعره
بطبيعه ايضا حتى البنيه التحتيه والمنازل
التي تم تشييدها في تلك المنطقه هناك
عائله باكملها جلال قضت تحت الانقاذ
تقريبا
لثوانا معدوده سقط المنزل بالكامل دقائق
لحتى تصل او يسمع انين واستغاثه هؤلاء
الاشخاص بمجرد وصول الجيران نحبهم جميعا
هناك الشهادات مخيفه في الحقيقه جلال ولكن
هناك صوره اخرى مثلا جار جيران هذا المنزل
الذي قضى هذه العائله التي توفيت باكملها
ايضا هدم بشكل كامل ونجوا جميع الافراد
العائله من هذه
الحادثه الاليمه هناك صور اخرى جلال في
هذه المنطقه حقيقه اولا هناك تكادف اسري
بالنظر الى علاقات المصاهره بين والقرابه
بين جميع عائلات
القريه قريه تفغين وايضا هناك عمل كبير تم
خلاله على الاقل الساعات الاولى كان هناك
صعوبه في الوصول الى هذه المنطقه الوعره
ايضا كان هناك كميه كبيره من الاتربه
والحجاره نزلت من الجبال نتيجه الارتداد
واغلقت الطرق وهو مع عقد مسئوليه مساله
الوصول الى تلك المنطقه الجبليه صعبه
التضاريس ولكن تم الوصول تم فتح الطرق
والوصول الى هذه المناطق تم تقديم
المعونات على الاقل الغذائيه السريعه على
الاقل لتخفيف من وطاه هذه
الفاجعه ومن ثم تم تركيز خيام في قامت بو
جهاز الوقايه اي الدفاع المدني هناك وتم
استقبال عدد من الاهالي في هذه الخيام
شكرا وبدات منظمات المجتمع المدني ايضا
تكثف جهودها في الوصول الى هذه المنطقه
لتخفيف الضغط وفي قبل ربما المساء وقبل
ساعه من الان لاحظنا وجود وفود طبيه وايضا
عمل على اضاءه على الاقل الخيام جلال حتى
تكون المنطقه مضاءه في هذه الساعات من
الليل جلال شكرا لك سيف الدين في اقليم
ازيلال ولشبكه مراسلين المنتشرين في
المناطق المتضرره من زلزال المغرب بصوتهم
كيف تحدث المنكوبون عن الماساه التي الم
عن اعزائهم الذين قضوا تحت الانقاض في
زلزال المغرب
نرى كينا وقيله 69 واحد اللي قالوا
لي عائله كلها مشات الوليد الوالده خويا
اعمامي بجوج ولد اختي
يا عمي راه الوالد الوليده اللهم
حتى حاجه واحد عمي اخر باقي
[موسيقى]
لا اله الا الله
الحمد لله والحمد لله صافي
ماما وخويا ماتو في هذا البيت
الدار البيضاء
وصلت هنايا وباقي ما كاين حتى واحد
شي حاجه
الله سبحانه وتعالى يجعل شي مخرج لهاد
الشعب
[موسيقى]
اعلانات وزاره الداخليه المغربيه في
بياننا السلطات المغربيه تستجابت في هذه
المرحله بالذات لعروض الدعم التي قدمتها
الدول الصديقه اسبانيا وقطر وبريطانيا
والامارات العربيه المتحده والتي اقترحت
تعبئه مجموعه من فرق البحث والانقاذ من
جهتي ذكر المغربيه ان السلطات المغربيه
اجرت تقييما دقيقه للاحتياجات في الميدان
اخذه بعين الاعتبار ان عدم التنسيق في مثل
هذه الحالات سيؤدي الى نتائج عكسيه
باسم الحكومه ان رئيس الحكومه سيتراس غدا
الاثنين اللجنه المكلفه باعاده بناء
المناطق المتضرره وكان رئيس الحكومه
المغربيه عزيز اخنوش قد قال ان حكومته
شكلت خليه ازمه تحت اشراف وزاره الداخليه
بناء على توجيهات العاهل المغربي واضاف
رئيس الحكومه المغربيه في حسابه على
فيسبوك انه سيتواصل اتخاذ التدابير التي
باشرتها الحكومه تنفيذا للتوجيهات الملكيه
الراميه الى متابعه ودعم جهود الاغاثه من
اجل ضمان حسن سير العمليات بحسب تعبيره
تواصل مجموعه البحث والانقاذ القطريه
الدوليه ارسال معدات واليات متخصصه الى
المغرب بالاضافه الى نقل مساعدات انسانيه
عاجله للتخفيف من معاناه المتضررين عقب
زلزال الذي ضرب عده اقاليم مغربيه وكانت
الدفعه الاولى من المجموعه قد وصلت الى
المغرب في وقت سابق من اليوم للمساهمه في
عمليه البحث والانقاذ
وقد وصلت مجموعه البحث والانقاذ القطري
الدوليه الى المغرب للمساهمه في عمليات
الاغاثه ودعم المتضررين من الزلزال وتشارك
المجموعه في عمليه البحث والانقاذ معززه
باليات ومعدات متخصصه بالاضافه الى
مساعدات انسانيه عاجله للتخفيف عن
المتضررين
وارسلت اسبانيا فريقا من 56 مسعفا الى
المغرب لدعم السلطات المحليه في عمليه
البحث والانقاذ لضحايا الزلزال واقلع
الطائره عسكريه من قاعده
الى مراكش تحمل على متنها قوات من وحده
الطوارئ العسكريه مكلفه بالمساعده في جهود
البحث والانقاذ وكان وزير الخارجيه
الاسباني حسام نويل الباريس اعلن في وقت
سابق ان مدريد ستقدم مساعده بقدر ما يحتاج
اليه المغرب مع التركيز على في البدايه
على انقاذ اكبر عدد ممكن من الضحايا الوقت
لاعاده الاعمار ستكون المساعده الاسبانيه
جاهزه ايضا
وقالت وكاله الانباء السعوديه ان العاهل
السعوديه الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز وولي
العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان وجها
بتسيير جسر جوي لتقديم المساعدات للمغرب
وقال المستشار بالديوان الملكي عبد الله
الربيعه ان فريق بحث وانقاذ وفريقا من
هيئه الهلال الاحمر السعودي
سيتوجهان الى المغرب للمشاركه في الاعمال
الاغاثيه والانسانيه
اصدرت دول عديده في قمه العشرين ومنظمات
دوليه بينها صندوق النقد الدولي بيانا
مشتركا للتضامن مع المغرب وفق البيان فقد
عبرت هذه الدول والمنظمات عن استعدادها
لتقديم كل الدعم اللاسم لاي احتياجات
ماليه عاجله على المدى القصير ولجهود
اعاده الاعمار
عندما من مراكش محمد مغاطيط رئيس جمعيه
النخيل للتبرع بالدم سيد محمد كيف تصف دور
المنظمات منظمات المجتمع المدني في
المساهمه في التخفيف على المتضررين في هذه
الازمه
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
تفضل سيد محمد نسمعك
الو سيد محمد نسمعك تفضل سالتك كيف تصل
كيف تصف عفوا دور المنظمات منظمات المجتمع
المدني في الدعم للتخفيف عن المتضررين
صراحه بالنسبه للتدخل ديال المجتمع المدني
باش نخفوا على على هاد الناس ولا عائله
هاد الناس اللي وقعت فيهم هاد الفاجعه فهو
كان في الدور ديالنا حنا من الشق ديالنا
ديال التبرع بالدم المجال ديال التبرع
بالدم بحكم اننا اليوم من 7:00 صباحا كان
توافق سيارات الاسعاف عند مستشفى الجامعي
محمد السادس كثير فيهم مجموعه ديال الناس
اللي جرحى وكان خاصهم انهم يتحقنوا بالدم
الحمد لله شفنا من الساعات الاولى ديال
الصباح واحد الطابورات ديال الناس والنداء
ديال المركز الجهوي تحاقن الدم و جمعيه
النخيل الوهبي الدم باش يجيو يتبرعوا
الاخوان ديالهم اللي اللي في هذا اللي
كانوا في هذا الماسات هذه وبالمناسبه انا
تنعزي جميع الناس والافراد اللي توفوا لهم
العائلات ديالهم صراحه يحزوا في النفس
اشنو الحاله اللي تيعيشوها الناس ديال
الاقاليم الحوزوا ومدينه مراكش حتى مدينه
مراكش كانت قريبه جدا من البؤره
كندعي والله المغفره
الى جانب التبرع بالدم ما ابرز ما تقدمه
الفعاليات ومنظمات المجتمع المدني لدعم
المتضررين من الزلزال
كاينين مجموعه ديال التبرعات فيها كيفاش
نجمعوا المؤن الغذائيه بحكم ان مجموعه
ديال الناس فقدوا المنازل ديالهم كانهم
ساعات ديال الوسط وسط النهار وتم النقل
ديالها الى المناطق اللي كان فيها الزنزات
مجموعه ديال الناس اللي يعاونوا عاونوا في
الاغاثه ديال الناس اللي باقي تحت الانقاذ
ديال المنازل ديالهم كانوا
ناسوا يعاونوا
مع الوقايه المدنيه وكانوا الناس اللي
وفروا الاغذيه والملابس الناس اللي فقدوا
المنازل ديالهم ما ابرز الاحتياجات في هذه
المرحله سيد محمد
ان الناس باقي ما لقاوش كيفاش يدوزوا
ويشوفوا العائلات ديالهم يخرجوهم من تحت
الانقاد وثاني حاجه بغينا الناس
شي شي خليه خليه ديال من عند وزاره
الداخليه ان شاء الله بس يكون هذاك نوفره
لهذوك الناس الماكل
[موسيقى]
والافريشه حتى تنسمعوا للناس الحمد لله
وبغينا لهم قيمه الماكل حيتاش
ما كاينش اللي اللي يوصل لهم المؤنث
الغذائيه لهم بالحديث عن الماكل كيف تصف
وضع المواد الاستهلاكيه والغذائيه في في
منطقه مثل مراكش مثلا
كل ما هو فيه الماء الحليب يعني
المواد الاساسيه كنت تكون مثلا واحد
الوجبه اللي واجده
الوجبات يعني الوجبه يعني
في المنزل ديال ديال الناس المجتمع المدني
ولا ديال الاخوان المتطوعين ويمشيوا لهذوك
الاقرب نقطه اللي اللي فيها البؤر الزلزال
اللي باقي بعض المناطق ما وصلوش لها الناس
في مدينه مراكش الحمد لله راه كاين كاين
كاينين كاينين
سوبرمان
اسواق اللي فيها اللي فيها اللي فيها اننا
نقدروا من عندها الناس باش يجيبوا يوصلوا
هذوك الناس شكرا لك محمد مغاطيط رئيس
جمعيه النخيل للتبرع بالدم في مراكش
اذا تركز الزلزال الذي ضرب المغرب في
دائره التاثر القصوى في مناطق يغلب عليها
الطابع الجبلي ما اوجد تحديه امام الفرق
الطبيه وفرق البحث والانقاذ التفاصيل
نتابعها في التقرير التالي
[موسيقى]
والزلزال الاقوى الذي يضرب المغرب منذ
ثلاثه قرون شدته ومركزه القريب من جبال
الاطلس حول الجغرافيا الى واحده من اكبر
التحديات امام فرق الانقاذ والبحر لكن
الاضرار والخسائر تفاوتت بين دائره التاثر
الاوسع التي وصلت الى مراكش واكادير
وقطرها 400 كيلو متر ومركز الزلزال في
اقليم الحوز بقطر 60 كيلو مترا تقريبا وهو
اقليم يغلب عليه الطابع الجبلي تغطي
الجبال ثلاثه ارباع مساحته
فاتت الاضرار في الحوض كبيره
الاقليم يضم نحو 40 قريه ومدينه وتجمعا
سكانيا اغلبه مناطق وعيره ويسكنه قرابه
600 الف نسمه تغلب الجبال على تضاريس
الحوز اذا وتعتبر قريه ايغيل على هضبه
محاطه بالجبال مركز الزلزال اما في
تارودانت فحجم الماساه كبير
تلتقي فيها سلسله جبال الاطلس الصغير
والاطلس الكبير تسببت الزلزال في حدوث
انهيارات صخريه في القرى الجبليه فدمر
بعضها بشكل شبه كامل
انهارت جل المباني الطينيه وتسببت الزلزال
في قطع الطرق بسبب الانهيارات الصخريه ما
ادى الى تعقيد عمليات الانقاذ
وتحولت بعض القرى النائيه الى اطلال بفعل
الدمار مع استمرار جهود الفرق الطبيه
للوصول
الى المناطق النائيه لحق الضرر مواقع
ثقافيه واثريه في تارودانت المدينه فالسور
التاريخي الاقدم في المغرب يحيط بها
وغالبيه سكانها يعيشون داخل اسوارها حتى
يومنا هذا
الى اقليم الشيشاوه اديسيل تحديدا قريه
جبليه سويت بالارض كليا يعتبر الاقليم
بموقعه الجغرافي ممرا ضروريا لمناطق جنوب
وغرب المغرب
الدكتور حسام فيصل رئيس وحده الازمات
والكوارث في الاتحاد الدولي لجمعيه الصليب
الاحمر والهلال الاحمر لمنطقه الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا دكتور كيف تساهمون
في عمليات الدعم والاغاثه في سيزال المغرب
مساء الخير لحضرتك
للمشاهده الاتحاد الدول
عباره عن شبكه من ما يزيد عن مئه وتسعين
جمعيه وطنيه احداها الهلال الاحمر المغربي
الهلال الاحمر المغربي كان على الارض في
الاستجابه لزلزال منزله الدقائق الاولى ما
بعد كنيسه الزلزال لتقديم خدمات الاسعاف
الاولي الدعم النفسي دعم خدمات الاجلاء
والاخلاء للمشافي
التقديم
الدعم الاغاثه ايضا كاتحاد دولي اطلقنا
البارحه مليون فرنك سويسري من صندوق
الاستجابه لحالات الكوارث من الاتحاد
الدولي لدعم انشطه الخدمات المقدمه من
الهلال الاحمر المغربي في مجالات الماء
والاصحاح في مجالات الايواء بالاضافه
للمجالات الاغاثيه الاخرى نعمل حاليا على
حشد طائره من المواد الاغاثيه من
مستودعاتنا الاقليميه في الامارات العربيه
المتحده لتتوجه الى المناطق المنكوبه ودعم
جهود الاستجابه كبدايه لرفع من حجم عمليات
الاستجابه كما نعمل ايضا مع زملائنا في
الهلال الاحمر المغربي على دعمها من
النواحي التقنيه لرفع عمليات الاستجابه
والنظر ليس فقط في عمليه الاستجابه
الطارئه ولكن ايضا في عمليات التعافي
والانتعاش المبكر دكتور ما تقييمكم
لصعوبات عمليات الانقاذ حتى الساعه
يوجد العديد من الصعوبات اهمها هي
التحديات الوصول بسبب طبيعه المناطق
المتضرره الطبيعه الجبليه وعوره الطرق مع
الاخذ بعين الاعتبار ايضا احدى التحليلات
التي تتوافر لدى فرقنا عن امكانيه التعرض
هذه المناطق في المغرب العربي
لهوب الرياح وايضا الامطار بسبب امور
التغير المناخير طبعا كان يوجد انقطاع في
الاتصالات بسبب انقطاع الكهرباء وهذا تحدي
اخر يعيق بدايه للمجتمعات المتضرره
التواصل من ضمن العائلات وايضا الوصول
لخدمات الطوارئ
هذا فيما يتعلق بعمليات البحث عن الناجين
ماذا عن الصعوبات فيما يتعلق بتقديم الدعم
للمشردين والمنكوبين حتى الان
طبعا يوجد العديد من التحديات بدايه لا
يوجد معلومات واضح حتى الان
[موسيقى]
من الصعوبه بمكان تحديدها هذا الموضوع
بشكل عام ولكن عاده ما نقول ان السبع ايام
الاولى اي حادثه زلزال هي هي ايام حرجه من
ناحيه الوصول للاشخاص الذين زالوا تحت
الانقاذ وزالوا ايضا على قيد الحياه كلما
ابتعدنا في الجدول الزمني عن الايام
الاولى كلما تضاءلت فرص الوصول لاشخاص
وتواجدهم على قيد الحياه بسبب العطش بسبب
ايضا الحراره وانخفاض حراره الجسم او
التعرض للصدمات مرحله الاستجابه الطارئه
لننظر اليها ايضا من اليوم الاول ننظر
ايضا الى عمليه الانتعاش المبكر والتعافي
من التاكد ان عمليات الاستجابه الطارئه لا
تعيق ولن تعيق عمليات التعافي واعاده
التاهيل في مراحل الاستجابه الطارئه او
بروتوكول الاستجابه الطارئه تامين مياه
الشفا وايضا الغذاء والدواء ما هي
الاولويه بالنسبه لكم دكتور ولمنظماتكم
الاولويه الاولى هي تامين الهواء وخدمات
الايواء التي تحفظ كرامه هؤلاء الاشخاص
الذين تضرروا من سبب الزلزال ويتضمن ايضا
حمايه الفئات الاشد ضعفا من هذه المجتمعات
المحليه خدمات لواء هي القطاع ذو الاولويه
يتلوه تقديم وبالتوازي خدمات المياه هو
الاصحاح المياه النظيفه خدمات الاصحاح
وتقديم ايضا المواد الغذائيه طبعا هذا لا
يخفي ولا يلغي ايضا بالتاكيد استمرار
تقديم الخدمات الصحيه والاسعافات الاوليه
من الناحيه الاسعافات الاوليه المتعارف
عليها ولكن ايضا خدمات الدعم النفسي
والصحه النفسيه للاشخاص الذين تعرضوا
للضرر ما بعد الكارثه يجب ان ناخذ بعين
الاعتبار كلما
اخذين بعض الخ
دمات على مشاكل نذكر على على سبيل المثال
كلما تاخرت توافر الخدمات المياه والاصحاح
على الجوده التي نتوقعها كلما ادى ذلك الى
زياده خطر
تفشي امراض تفشي او بيئه بين هؤلاء
المتضررين شكرا لك الدكتور حسام فيصل رئيس
وحده الازمات والكوارث في الاتحاد الدوليه
لجمعيه الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر
لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
وقد اعتبر خبراء الزلزال ان درجه الزلزال
الذي ضرب مناطق في المغرب قبل يومين لافته
ويقول علماء انه كان من المستحيل التنبؤ
بمثل زلزال اقليم الحوز وبالقوه التي وصل
اليها التقرير التالي يوضح الاسباب التي
جعلت وقوع الزلزال حدثا مفاجئا بالنسبه
لعلماء الجيولوجيا
ان شهد المغرب مثل قوه زلزال الثامن من
سبتمبر تعادل قوه الزلزال 25 قنبله نوويه
انها مفاجاه حقيقيه ستعيد لا محاله خلط
الاوراق امام العلماء هذا ما يقوله خبراء
الزلازل لكن لماذا كل هذه الحيره
مسلمات الجيولوجيا هي منبع هذه الحيره
تحدث الزلازل في المناطق الواقعه عند
الحدود الفاصله بين الصفائح التكتونيه
فاليابان واندونيسيا وتركيا وايطاليا
واليونان مناطق ناشطه زلزاليا في شمال
افريقيا تقع المغرب مثل الجزائر وتونس
اقصى شمال الصفيحه التكتونيه الافريقيه
تتقابل الصفيحه الافريقيه مع الصفيحه
الاوروسيه والتي تضم اوروبا واسيا معا
باستثناء شبه القاره الهنديه وشبه الجزيره
العربيه
تغوص الصفيحه الافريقيه اسفل الصفيحه
الاوراسيه فنجد ان مناطق اليونان وقبرص
والدول المطله على البحر المتوسط تشهد
وقوع العديد من الزلازل بين الفينه
والاخرى تمر منطقه الاتصال بين الصفيحتين
الاوروسيه والافريقيه بشمال المغرب
والجزائر لذلك من الطبيعي جدا حدوث
الزلازل في المدن التي تقع عند الحد
الفاصل بين الصفيحتين التكتونيتين لكن
بشكل عام تقع منطقه المغرب العربي في
منطقه زلزاليه متوسطه وفقا للسجل
الجيولوجي فان الجزائر هي الاكثر نشاطا في
حين توصف تونس بانها الاقل تاتي المغرب في
وضع متوسط ذلك انها تتحرك مع كتله جبال
الاطلس
في عام 1960 هز زلزال مدينه اغادير واوده
بحياه اكثر من 12 الف شخص لم تكن قوه
الزلزال كبيره لكن مركزه كان اسفل مدينه
اغادير مباشره وفي عام
1980 تسبب زلزال في ولايه الشلف الاصنام
سابقا في شمال الجزائر في مقتل اكثر من
خمسه الاف شخص وبقوه سبع درجات وثلاثه
اعشار ويعتبر الاقوى في غرب البحر الابيض
المتوسط حتى الان وفي شمال الجزائر ايضا
ضرب زلزال عام 2003 منطقه بومرداس وبلغت
قوته 6 درجات وثمانيه اعشار واوقع
2266 قتيلا لكن خصوصيه زلزال الثامن من
سبتمبر والمفاجئه في هذه المره انه حدث
داخل صفيحه التكتونيه وليس عند اطرافها او
حدودها مع صفيحه اخرى فوفقا لهيئه المسح
الجيولوجي الامري فان مركز الزلزال كان
قرب بلده ايغيل في اقليم الحوز على بعد 71
كيلو مترا جنوب غربي مراكش وعلى عمق 18
كيلو مترا ونصف فاقليم الحوز الذي كان
الاكثر تضررا يبعد عن حد التصادم بين
صفيحه الافريقيه والاوروسيه بنحو 500
كيلومتر الى الجنوب منها وبالتالي كان
العلماء يستبعدون حدوث زلازل بهذه القوه
في تلك المنطقه لم يشهد المغرب زلزالا
بهذه القوه منذ 100 عام على الاقل بل يقول
العلماء انه كان من المستحيل التنبؤ بمثل
زلزال اقليم الحوز فالحركه في المناطق
البعيده عن حدود الصفائح بطيئه للغايه
وغير قادره على توليد زلزال بمثل هذه
القوه لكن من الواضح ان زلزال المغرب
سيغير الكثير من النظريات لدى علماء
الزلازل والجيولوجيا
في جامعه ييل دكتور جفري
زلزال مدمر اخر في المغرب سبع درجات على
بقياس ريختر بعد زلزال سابق في تركيا
كهرمان مراش في فبراير الماضي 7.8 على
مقياس رخصه رختر ما تفسير هذا
نعم نحن هنا
نتحدث عن زلزال يحدث في منطقه جبال الاطلس
وهذه المنطقه لها خصائص جيولوجيه واضحه
وبالتاكيد خدعت لمسح جيولوجي خاص
بعلم الزلازل نحن نعرف ان المناطق الجبليه
تخضع دائما الى نوع من النشاط الزلزالي
ونشاط الجيولوجيه واعتقد ان هذه الزلازل
تحدث في حيز الاف من السنين ليس من
المفاجئه ان نرى زلزال بهذا الحجم في هذا
الوقت
والعمق الذي تم تنزيله وحوالي عشرين كيلو
متر تحت الارض واعتقد ان هناك
ميكانيزمات لتحديد اثار
قوه هذا النوع من الزلازل نسمع كثيرا عن
التغيرات المناخيه والتاثيراتها على
البيئه والطبيعه هل لها اي تاثير على حدوث
زلازل سيد جفري
قد يكون هناك بعض التاثير بشكل لكن هذا
الزلزال الان بدا في عمق يصل الى حوالي
عشرين او 25 كلم تحت الارض اذن لا اعتقد
ان هناك علاقه بين زلزال والتغيير المناخي
هل تعتقد ان المنطقه منطقه الزلزال تخطت
ما يعرف بالهزات الارتداديه
غايه الان كانت هناك مجموعه من الهزات
الارتداديه
واعتقد ان هذه الهزات الارتداديه الان
تراجعت في قوتها
وتحدث الكثير من العلماء حول هذا الموضوع
لكن لكن قد تكون هناك بعض
الهزات الاعتداديه لكن قد نشهد ايضا
زلزال اخر يضرب منطقه اخرى من تلك الصفيحه
فمن التصريح التكتونيه اذن قد نشهد ذلك
وبعد سنه او خمس سنوات لماذا تعتقد بان
زلزالا اخر سيضرب هذه المنطقه ما المؤشرات
نعم
هناك الدراسه تم القيام بها في مجموعه من
المناطق عبر العلم في ذلك تركيا في شمال
الاناضول
سجلنا مجموعه من الزلازل في القرن العشرين
بدات
شرق البلاد وانتقلت الى اسطنبول في
1999 كما يذكر الجميع
اذا يمكن حساب
امكانيه وقوع الزلزال تبعا للحركه
التكتونيه والحركه الزلزاليه في منطقه
معينه وقد ياتي ذلك الزلزال بعد سنوات او
حتى بعد عقود ان
شكرا لك
استاذ الجيولوجيا في جامعه ييل شكرا لك
تتجهوا كذلك الجهود الى التقييم الاضرار
في مباني تاريخيه تمثل جانبا من التراث
الاثري المغربي خاصه في المدينه القديمه
بمراكش او في اقليم الحوز وضع دفع يونسكو
الى التحرك للمساعده على حصر الاضرار
ومتابعه ترميم وانقاذ هذه المواقع
مراكش ثالث اكبر مدينه في المملكه
المغربيه من حيث عدد السكان تاسست في
القرن الثاني عشر وبنى فيها المرابطون
العديد من المعالم التاريخيه
ادرجت مدينه مراكش في قوائم اليونسكو
للتراث العالمي واعطت الجدران الحمراء
للمدينه ومختلف المباني التي شيدت من
الحجر الرملي الاحمر لقب المدينه الحمراء
لكن وضع المدينه انقلب مع زلزال بقوه نحو
سبع درجات على سلم الاختر كان مركزه في
اقليم الحوز المجاور بمثل ما تضررت بسببه
مبال ومنشات فقد كانت المواقع والمعالم
الاثريه عرضه كذلك لاضرار جغرافيا تقع
مراكش على بعد نحو 327 كيلومترا جنوب شرق
العاصمه المغربيه الرباط ومن معالمها التي
تضررت هيكل مجد الكتبيه التاريخي ويعود
تاريخه الى القرن الثاني عشر وتعرف مئذنته
التي يبلغ ارتفاعها 69 مترا باسم سقف
مراكش ولم يتضح حجم الاضرار التي لحقت به
المدينه القديمه لمراكش والتي يطلق عليها
اسم المدينه العتيقه تعرضت بدورها لاضرار
بالغه بسبب الزلزال بنيت بين عامي 71 و72
كعاصمه لدوله المرابطيه ثم للدوله
الموحديه وتضم مجموعه من الاثار وتميزها
اسورها وابوابها وكذلك المنازل التقليديه
القديمه من رياضات وغيرها بطبع مغربي قديم
متميز وقد سجلت عام 85 ضمن قائمه التراث
العالمي لليونسكو كما نشر مغاربه مقاطع
فيديو تظهر تضرر اجزاء من اسوار مراكش
الدفاعيه التاريخيه التي شيدت لاول مره في
مطلع القرن الثاني عشر وهي عباره عن جدران
ترابيه حمراء تحيط بوسط المدينه القديمه
ومدرجه على لائحه اليونسكو للتراث العالمي
على مسافه 19 كلم حول المدينه ويصل
ارتفاعها الى 19 قدما ولديها 20 بوابه و
100 برج على طولها اما في ساحه جامع
الفناء التي يرجع تاريخها الى عهد تاسيس
مدينه مراكش ويقترن بها فقد انهارت صومعه
ماجد خربوش وتضررت المحل التجاريه لصناع
التقليديين بالسوق المجاور من المعالم
التي لم تسلم من الزلزال ماجد تيمال او
المسجد الاعظم الذي يقع في اقليم الحوز
الذي يعد مركز الزلزال هو مجد تاريخي بني
في عهد الخليفه عبد المؤمن بن علي الموحدي
حوالي
1153 ميلاديه وتعرض لاضرار كبيره بسبب
الزلزال وتفاعلا مع تعرض هذه المعالم
وغيرها للاضرار والدمار قالت المديره
العامه لليونسكو ادريس انها توجهت مع بعثه
من اليونسكو لمدينه مراكش لدعم السلطات
المغربيه في حصر الاضرار والعمل على اعاده
الاعمار
شهدت العديد من ملاعب كره القدم الاوروبيه
والافريقيه موجه كبيره من التضامن مع
ضحايا زلزال المغرب حيث وقف اللاعبون
دقيقه صمت قبل انطلاق المباريات كما عبر
العديد من النجوم العالميين عن تعاطفهم من
خلال حساباتهم على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي
القى الزلزال المدمر الذي شهده المغرب
مساء الجمعه بظلال الحزن التي وصل صداها
لكل انحاء العالم
ملاعب كره القدم واستجابه لما اعلنه
الاتحاد الاوروبي للعبه عرفت موجه واسعه
من التضامن حيث شهدت التصفيات الاوروبيه
الوقوف دقيقه صمت قبل المباريات حدادا على
ارواح الضحايا الذين سقطوا خلال اليومين
الماضيين
على روح
اهالينا في زلزال المغرب الامر ذاته تكرر
في الملاعب الافريقيه وتحديدا خلال مبارتي
موريتانيا والجابون وكذلك الكونغو
الديمقراطيه ضد السودان الدعاء بالشفاء
للمصابين ان شاء الله
وجه اخر مشرق من اوجه التضامن والتكافل
كان ابطاله لاعب المنتخب المغربي لكره
القدم الذين تبرعوا بالدم في احد المراكز
بمدينه اكادير لفائده المتضررين من
الزلزال الذي ضرب اقليم الحوز وشارك جميع
نجوم اسود الاطلس في هذا العمل الانساني
اضافه للمدرب وليد الركراكي تلبيه
للمناشدات التي اطلقتها السلطات المغربيه
وعرفت استجابه شعبيه كبيره مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي بدورها غصت بموجات من التضامن
مع المغرب حيث عمدت الصفحات الرسميه لبعض
انديه ودوريات كره القدم العالميه الى
تقديم التعازي ورسائل التضامن لاسر
الضحايا مؤكدين وقوفهم مع الشعب المغربي
في هذه المحنه وهو نفس الشيء الذي قام به
نجوم عالميون مثل البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو والمصري محمد صلاح فضلا عن رئيس
الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم
السويسري